[Music]
on this Saturday night turbulent times
at Air Canada the struggling carrier
plans to lay off more workers
will the federal government bailout the
airline industry we are going to need
airlines afterwards who will pick the
produce the demand for seasonal workers
in Canada plus limits on vaping new
restrictions on e-cigarettes and the
future of concerts can the show go on
somehow
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with the
unprecedented toll Cova 19 is taking on
the travel industry air canada says it
will have to lay off 20,000 employees
more than half its workforce travel has
tanked with countries shutting down and
the entire global airline industry is in
trouble
as Mike jala reports the Prime Minister
still hasn't offered a bailout to
Canada's airline sector with no end to
the pandemic in sight the airline
industry is looking for a lifeline at
Air Canada it can't get much worse with
layoffs affecting 20,000 staff next
month you know I think we reached the
bottom for sure so you know what are we
gonna do further down to that and all
eyes were on Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau and his daily media briefing
when asked about the airline industry
he offered nothing in all sectors of the
economy but certain sectors have been
hit even harder that's why we're gonna
keep working with various sectors we're
gonna continue to work with sectors his
non-response was met with frustration
from industry insiders who've seen every
other g7 country come up with measures
to support their domestic aviation
sector and they got a master plan they
got something you know as they indicated
that the and I would be reassuring we
have no indications that they have any
direction in what they're doing other
than putting out fires Trudeau was asked
about a bailout similar to the one in
the US and nationalization as Italy is
done with air Alitalia again he offered
no response other than to point to wage
subsidy programs already in place I
don't have the crystal water I can't
tell you what is really sticking up but
but we're gonna have to find a solutions
because we need them we're gonna need a
Canada right so nationalization is a
possibility getting some private equity
into it why not but who would be willing
to buy into the industry right now the
montreal-based
International Air Transport Association
has painted a grim picture with Travel
dropping 90% in Canada the US and Europe
it's estimating passenger traffic won't
rebound to pre-crisis levels until at
least 2020 three
even later if restrictions are extended
another issue for Canadian airlines is
only the largest qualify for the
government loan program leaving smaller
airlines vulnerable which would create
an even bigger problem most important is
that in many many regions there is no
other way to connect all those regions
and through the smaller airlines the
larger airlines are key to our newest
economic development but the smaller
airlines are our lifeline to many
regions yes if acquittal if Trudeau has
a plan in the works he hasn't said
leaving the airline industry financially
grounded microlight Global News Toronto
families across Canada are also
struggling and this month there will be
more financial help for those with
children on Wednesday those eligible for
the Canada child benefit will receive an
extra $300 per child as part of their
regular May payment and in the summer
Ottawa will give families another boost
to help with rising costs starting on
July 20th we will increase the Canada
child benefit once again for the
upcoming year every summer for the past
three years we boosted the CCB to help
keep up with the cost of living this
summer will be no different that will
raise the maximum benefit to just over
6700 dollars per child under the age of
six and just under six thousand dollars
per child aged 6 through 17 the
government has also allocated 40 million
dollars to help women fleeing domestic
violence today the Minister for women
and gender equality said the money is
being shared among 500 shelters as well
as centers supporting victims of sexual
assault the federal government also
committed fifteen million dollars to
support female entrepreneurs to help
their businesses through the economic
crisis caused by Cova 19 the funding
will go directly to organizations that
are already part of the government's
women entrepreneurship strategy fund
which provides support for women who
want to start or grow a business Health
Canada has approved the first clinical
trial of a kovat 19 vaccine human trials
will begin at the Canadian Centre for
vaccinology at
a university in Halifax the National
Research Council of Canada has been
working closely with Cansino biologics
in China which created the vaccine using
living cells grown by scientists here in
Canada that research is in the second
phase of human trials according to the
World Health Organization there are
about a hundred other potential vaccines
that are in the early stages of
development I think this is just the
first of a number of them and that's
very important to have multiple vaccines
going through the process because we
need to have that redundancy we need not
all vaccines ultimately will work and in
order to make sure that we have more
than one that works we need to be
studying a number of vaccines and here's
the breakdown of cases in Canada there
are more than 75,000 confirmed cases of
kovat 19 across the country about half
have now recovered from the new corona
virus across Canada more than 5,600
Canadians have died Quebec remains the
hardest-hit province with more than
42,000 confirmed cases and more than
3,400 deaths a new Cova 19 outbreak has
been confirmed at another Canadian food
processing plant at least three people
at the Oppenheimer group fruit and
vegetable plant in BC have tested
positive for the virus the facility
remains open and Public Health is
investigating Canada's fruit and
vegetable growers have been hit hard by
the pandemic not only are they facing
financial losses but as David Icahn
explains they're now facing a new
problem a labor shortage David well
Robin the country's fruit and vegetable
farmers are saying that the Canadian
workers they would normally hire in the
spring are preferring instead to stay at
home and collect the candidate emergency
response benefit or serve the serve pays
$2,000 a month given the choice between
taking a serb check picking up seasonal
work on a farm or taking a full time job
in one of Canada's food processing
plants many Canadians are choosing to
take the serve and that's causing a big
problem for the country's food producers
there is
still a critical shortage of workers on
some farms companies that operate the
country's food processing plants told
the House of Commons committee on Friday
that they've got ten thousand vacant
jobs they cannot fill the Serb has
created unintended consequences in the
short term for many Packers distributors
wholesalers and small retailers who are
facing greater challenges the hire at a
time when Canadians are relying on them
to provide the food they need more than
seven and a half million Canadians are
receiving the $2,000 a month serb to get
that benefit a recipient cannot earn
more than $1,000 a month going to work
on a farm or in a plant would put them
over the limit a Canadian emergency
relief benefit or Serb has had an
adverse impact on numbers ability to
fill positions so we wish to partner
with the government on a program to help
incentivize Canadians to work in our
industry food producers also rely
heavily on temporary foreign workers to
plant and to harvest the industry says
that Ontario and Atlantic producers have
received just three quarters of the
foreign workers they normally employ at
this time of year while Quebec and BC
farmers have received barely half of the
foreign workers that they need and
producers are now warning that because
there were not enough hands on the farm
this spring there may be a shortage of
Canadian fruits and vegetables this fall
Robert David akin in Ottawa thanks David
the World Health Organization has issued
an alert about a dangerous condition
affecting children that may be linked to
Cova 19 doctors are being urged to look
for pediatric multi-system inflammatory
syndrome in the past few weeks there
have been reports of kids being admitted
to hospital with symptoms similar to
Kawasaki disease and toxic shock
syndrome
it's believed this syndrome may be
related to Cova 19 the whu-oh says
there's an urgent need for more clinical
data in the United States Donald Trump
is downplaying the threat of new
outbreaks as states reopened restaurants
and bars the u.s. president insists the
nation has to rebuild its economy while
promising a vaccine by the end of the
year
House has passed another economic aid
bill for struggling Americans but the
republican-led Senate says the bill is
dead on arrival here's Jennifer Johnson
from the Grand Canyon to some California
restaurants it's like Christmas Day and
even casinos in Oklahoma I'm pretty
excited to get out of the house after
two months almost every state in America
is reopening at least partially
including some regions and popular
beaches in the hardest hit states like
New York and New Jersey as
hospitalization rates continue to go
down lawmakers still urging social
distancing we write about where we were
when we started we just don't want to
make sure we don't go back to the hell
that we've gone through u.s. President
Donald Trump is urging states to get
back to business
even though just 3% of the population
has been tested for the virus every day
last week over a thousand Americans died
of kovat 19 but the president is now
predicting hundreds of millions of doses
of a yet to be developed vaccine by
year's end even while many health
experts say that's unrealistic we'd love
to see if we could do it prior to the
end of the year I just want to make
something clear it's very important
vaccine or no vaccine we're back the
president also saying the corona virus
may just disappear without a vaccine and
he's still not wearing a mask despite a
Food and Drug Administration alert that
the test kit used at the White House and
elsewhere may be missing up to half of
all positive cases the heroes bill is
passed
meanwhile there's a new showdown between
the President and House Democrats who
late Friday passed another economic aid
bill this one with a three trillion
dollar price tag to help the unemployed
renters and homeowners make ends meet
the Democrats bill would give each
taxpayer another $1,200 but President
Trump says there's no way he's signing
it Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington the u.s. still has far more
cases of Cova 19 than anywhere else in
the world it's now closing in on 1.5
million cases and over 88,000 deaths the
u.s. accounts for more than 30% of the
world's 4.6 million cases globally 310
thousand people have died from the virus
Russia just recorded its highest daily
death toll 119 new fatalities in the
last 24 hours
in Spain health authorities reported a
hundred and two nuke deaths
that's the lowest number of deaths in a
day since mid-march
italy has also recorded its lowest
number of deaths in a 24-hour period
since early March at 153 that government
is now starting to ease travel
restrictions starting Monday people will
be allowed to move freely inside the
region where they live and as of June
3rd international travel will be allowed
Italy imposed a nationwide lockdown in
early March dr. became the first country
outside of Asia with a major outbreak of
the virus coming up new restrictions on
vaping plus the travel restrictions
separating newborns and their parents
health experts say smokers and vapors
are at much higher risk of contracting
kovin 19 smoking damages the lungs and
that weakness allows the virus to thrive
Nova Scotia has introduced candidates
toughest anti-v legislation by limiting
the amount of nicotine levels in east
cigarettes as Ross Lord reports that
province is leading the charge to
protect young people from becoming
addicted and suffering harmful side
effects Nova Scotia is capping nicotine
content in a liquids at almost
two-thirds lower than many current
vaping products the government says the
new limit will protect youth and the
province from the harms of nicotine and
smoking opponents agree having this
maximum nicotine level of 20 milligrams
per milliliter will make these products
less addictive it's going to reduce
youth vaping is something that's been in
place in the European Union for several
years Nova Scotia is considered a leader
in vaping restrictions but all provinces
are taking action BC is also limiting
nicotine to 20 milligrams per milliliter
and raising taxes Alberta is hiking
taxes and reviewing smoking legislation
Saskatchewan and Manitoba are
restricting the sale of vaping products
to people 18 and older in Ontario sales
are confined to specialty stores New
Brunswick and Newfoundland and Labrador
are limiting sales to people 19 and
older and PEI has raised the legal age
to buy tobacco and e-cigarettes from 19
to 21 the highest age limit in Canada in
addition to Nova Scotia's new nicotine
limits it was the first in Canada to
announce a ban on flavored East
cigarettes and juices before the
pandemic vaping was a growing public
health issue attributed to dozens of
deaths in the US and more than a dozen
cases of long illness in Canada although
medical researchers cannot yet prove
vaping is connected to serious illness
from Kovac 19 they say there are other
risks than someone vapes and emits the
secondhand vapor to someone next by
those droplets can transfer to someone
else and they can get infected because
of that doctors say there's still more
work
do like providing online suppliers from
violating the new rules and educating
consumers I really want to see us
working on a public awareness campaign
and educating youth in particular who
have really sort of launched into this
idea that it's out there and
commercially available therefore it
can't be that bad for you
Canadian vaping Association says it
agrees with the cap on nicotine levels
but it wants Nova Scotia's flavor ban
amended and taxation restructured the
new restrictions take effect in
September
Ross lor Global News Windsor Nova Scotia
families Beyond Borders still ahead the
parents blocked from their babies due to
Coppa 19
some babies born to surrogate mothers in
Ukraine have been stranded their parents
who are foreigners can't get into the
country because the borders have been
closed now they're appealing to the
Ukrainian government to help end the
heartache here's reverend shannon
bundles of joy in an age of anxiety
dozens and dozens of temporary orphans
the full closure of Ukraine's borders
means no one knows when these newborns
will meet their parents we tried to send
parents pictures says the clinic's owner
but it cannot substitute any direct
contact the company's lawyer says
Ukraine is only granting access to
parents from countries whose embassies
apply for special travel exemptions and
ask other countries to make an exception
from their policy and to let their
citizens united with their children the
parents who have made it or stuck in
quarantine for two weeks with most
flights canceled one Swedish couple
needed a private jet there are currently
51 babies awaiting the arrival of their
parents but if the lockdown continues as
forecast the number of babies could
reach 1,000 according to Ukraine's Human
Rights Ombuds woman
she suggested a change in the law to ban
foreign circuses in Ukraine prospective
parents go there because of those laws
and the cost significantly less than in
Canada for many parents in various
countries with bringing babies home from
countries like the Ukraine in Georgia
Cindy Wasser specializes in fertility
law and says Canada remains one of the
best places for surrogacy what I would
like to point
it's for those in the future to consider
what and where they will go and what
they will do to choose something better
so they're never in this position again
Ottawa is allowing entry to foreign
parents who have a surrogate baby born
in Canada as long as they are not
showing covert 19 symptoms in Ukraine
these tiny miracles remain oblivious to
the heartache their parents are feeling
Redman Shannon Global News London the
shows can't go on
up next the uncertain future facing the
music industry well I suppose all
parents wondered how things would have
changed if they had a different child
I didn't didn't mean a different one
Fred Willard has been making audiences
laugh with his distinct brand of comedic
acting on hit shows like Modern Family
and screen favorites like anchorman he
started his career in the famed second
city comedy troupe he was a fixture in
mockumentary style comedies like this is
spinal tap waiting for Guffman and Best
in Show he's set to appear in the new
Netflix series space force later this
month his family says he passed away
last night of natural causes Fred
Willard was 86 from locked-down
sing-alongs on balconies to virtual
choirs we've seen people around the
world turned to music during this
pandemic but the music industry is
facing its own crisis as the list of
canceled shows continues to grow Nadia
Stewart reports the Rolling Stones were
set to play in Vancouver in May but the
band canceled the show
adding to a list of live shows not
hitting the stage this year because of
kovat 19th we're in uncharted territory
so Paul Reynolds is the co-owner of a
company behind many of BC's live shows
he says the economic loss from major
events like it's cannot be understated
that event alone is 150 million dollars
economic activity on an annual basis so
you look at something like that and then
you think about you know the numbers of
concerts in arena shows and stadium
shows and the minutes it multiplies up
very very quickly instead we have
decided we are going to
play a show to nobody maybe can we swirl
the camera around and show this just a
handful of people here
Vancouver musician Dan Mangan had shows
lined up for the spring and summer and I
have another sinking feeling that that
spring tour is gonna get postponed once
again until next fall now he's looking
at how to effectively host concerts
online using a platform he helped create
he says concerts of the future have
forever been changed because of this
pandemic I see
long after Cova this behavior will
continue and I think that what you'll
start to see is that you could attend a
show in person for you know one ticket
tear and then maybe for a much lower
ticket tear you could also stream it
from home in a survey earlier this week
over 50 percent to Vancouver writes said
they would not go to a live concert or
sporting event again unless there is a
vaccine brenell says there are many
artists longing to be back on stage but
the uncertainty means when that will
happen we don't even know what that
calendar looks like is it starting in
the fall is it starting you know in the
winter is starting at spring is it
starting next summer with the
uncertainty of this virus that's
anybody's guess
Nadia Stewart Global News Vancouver and
that is global national for this
Saturday I'm Robin Gill remember captain
Tom Moore the British vet who's a
hundredth birthday goal of a hundred
garden laps raised millions for the
health care system tonight
one Canadian was inspired to one up and
that marks a hundred and one lapse for a
hundred and one year old John Hillman
but it's not stopping him war vet plans
to keep walking and fundraising for two
more weeks so far he's raised over a
hundred and forty thousand dollars for
Save the Children Canada thank you for
watching good night
[Music]